damn short film festival is back for its
18th year and it is ready to showcase
some of the top up and coming filmmakers
from across the globe the pandemic
created an opportunity to garner even
more support of course there is no
question that southern nevada draws from
a worldwide pool of talent but there's
no shortage of homegrown creativity here
either
you can build a whole world and
you can do it in three minutes the damn
short film festival in boulder city has
proven just how successful short films
can be many of these films will stick
with you for the rest of your life
before the pandemic film buffs would
pack the historic boulder theater to
take in a variety of genres but last
year the beloved film festival had to go
virtual it's actually been incredibly
successful for us we have been able to
reach a brand new
worldwide audience and once again this
year it's all online with more than a
thousand submissions each year filmmaker
anais tomasion is part of an elite group
they're one of the best
i think film festivals that i've ever
been a part of
want some breakfast mama oh you know
what i am watching my figure but it
looks delicious it is dude her seven
minute piece crackle is about the loss
of innocence we are who we are based on
our experiences and her experience as a
producer and actress has kept her here
in southern nevada the film community in
vegas is
so supportive from one studio to the
other but now in this virtual world
where art can be consumed and shared
everywhere tomaseon says it's opening
new doors and opportunities i'm just so
grateful to be able to to do this and i
think now
even more so than ever
the damn short film festival is february
10 through the 14th 23 programs in total
you can buy individual tickets for each
film or you can buy a pass to see them
all there's also a virtual filmmaker
lounge that you can take part in